-You´re doing a Broadway show.
You´re doing it every night.
Obviously one of the risks,
I would think, of doing a show
is that if you have to do
the same material every night.
You went a little outside
of what you usually did.
You took your whole audience,
and you went
and protested at Trump Tower.
-Yes. At the end of the show
the other night, I asked them,
´cause Trump
had just arrived in town here.
-Yeah.
-And, by the way,
I´m glad he waited --
After going
to West Virginia and Ohio,
he comes to New York.
He waited till he got here
to announce his support
for the Confederacy.
-Yes. Very strange.
-I just thought that was very --
-Yeah.
-Very smart. And, uh...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And I asked --
I asked the audience at the end,
"How would you like to go over
to Trump Tower and greet him?
He hasn´t stayed overnight
here since the inauguration.
-Yeah. And it was --
You had some --
Here you are --
There you are with Olivia Wilde.
-Yes, she was there.
She was there, yes.
-There´s Mark Ruffalo.
-Marissa Tomei.
-Fisher Stevens.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How much do you think --
-We put everybody
on double-decker buses.
-Oh, wow.
So you just bused them over.
-From the theater,
yes, over there.
And he wouldn´t see us.
-He wouldn´t see you?
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
-How much do you think
it hurts him when New Yorkers
are upset to see him?
-A lot.
-Yeah.
-A lot. I was there
at the very first demonstration
the night after he was elected.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, legally,
the legal term is
appointed
by the Electoral College.
-Yeah. Sure, yeah, yeah.
-But he was --
He was tweeting at us
from up there.
-Yeah.
-Like, "Protesters --
Protesters say
I´m not legitimate.
Unfair!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
And I was like...
-Yeah.
-"Wow!" you know?
And so we went back this time,
and I thought,
certainly, with Marissa Tomei
and Olivia Wilde -- right?
-Yeah.
-That would really upset him.
-Yeah, no.
I think you´re right.
-That´s the demographic he would
like to appeal to the most.
-Yes. He would like to believe
that they like him.
-Now, your show --
One of the things in your show
is the 12-step program
for helping people
sort of deal
with this Trump presidency.
And you´ve
just added another step.
-Yes, yes.
The new step --
I just added it last night --
was we have
to sober the [bleep] up.
-Okay, great.
[ Laughter ]
So, what do you mean?
[ Applause ]
-I mean...
What I mean by that is,
we have to keep --
We´re saying,
"Oh, he´s gonna be impeached."
Every time something happens --
James Comey.
I tell everybody
in the audience,
"Please put your whiskey bottles
and your flasks
on the table right now.
´cause every month,
you´re drinking from a new --
You know, "James Comey --
That´s the end of him!
Ha ha ha ha!"
-Yeah.
-You know?
"Oh, Russia!
That´s gonna be the end of him.
Ha ha ha ha!"
You know, and it´s -- it´s --
And now this week,
the press conference
and the C.E.O.s desert him.
You know, "Oh, that´ll be
the end of him now."
You know?
And, no.
-Yeah. So we´re giving ourselves
cirrhosis of the liver,
and he´s fine.
-He´s fi--
He´s not going anywhere.
-Yeah.
-He´s not the Teflon president.
Teflon implies --
You have to be in the pan.
He´s not even in the pan.
-Yeah.
-This guy
gets away with everything.
He´s -- The Republicans --
I´m sorry to say this --
They´re not
going to impeach him.
-Right.
-They´re not --
They´ve already pulled
their gerrymandered districts,
and they know --
Most of them think
they´re gonna get re-elected.
So they´re
not gonna impeach him.
Mueller, the special prosecutor,
he can´t indict the president.
I mean, he can be indicted
after he´s impeached, and --
I think -- I was telling
your producer backstage.
I think the problem is gonna be,
that when he
is indicted or arrested,
do we try him as an adult?
-Yeah, that´s a good question.
That´s a good question.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I hadn´t even
thought about that.
It´s really problematic.
-I think he has to be
tried as an adult.